earlier this year the online servers for
dark souls 1 2 and 3 all went down for a
quote issue with online services what it
actually ended up being according to
this post on the eldon ring subreddit
was a remote code execution exploit that
was found accessing the dark souls 3
servers now what that means is there was
a piece of code that could be run
remotely from a hacker system onto yours
should you play that game in question
online and this means that that piece of
code could result in oh pretty much
anything if it got to run on your
computer from reading your data to
stealing your data to locking down your
computer some of you might remember the
wannacry virus that affected windows 10
pcs which was pretty much the same thing
i remember it well i worked geek squad
at the time it was a bad time when
hackers attempt a sinister move like
this normally it's to steal data and
either use it to access stuff like your
banking information or your email or
hold your data hostage by running
malicious software that blocks you from
accessing it until you pay what they
want or whatever and then you might get
your data back but you might not it's up
to the good graces of the thief if that
sounds scary that's because honestly it
is it's called ransomware and it was a
very real threat for those affected by
wannacry and for the dark souls players
earlier this year in january which was
before eldon ring's release in february
and was supposed to be patched now i'm
not sure if this was the reason behind
the fact that eldon ring has just been
hacked but something like this must have
happened to one of these games as
servers because someone did indeed get
hacked in two only it wasn't us the
players like bandai namco was worried
about it was bandai namco themselves
talk about a plot twist on monday the
11th new sites like kotaku and twitter
accounts like vx underground stated that
the notorious digital organized crime
group known as black cat or alphv has
officially claimed bandai namco in their
rapidly growing ransomware scheme that's
encompassed many different companies so
far including the likes of the mega
german fuel company gmbh and the
aviation company swissport now i know
that kind of made black cats sound kinda
cool in an edgy way but they're kinda
scumbags who steal data and then hold it
for ransom now asking apparently upwards
of 2.5 million us dollars for all of it
so maybe don't feel too good about them
and this sort of thing has been
happening to game companies more often
in recent years like when nvidia got
attacked and kingdom hearts 4 was leaked
or when cd projekt red had source code
stolen the pattern so far has been that
these hackers will slowly begin to
increase the pressure and leak data
until the companies decide to pay what
they're asking so it's possible that
some upcoming elden ring content may be
getting maliciously leaked soon because
it is bandai namco's biggest hit
currently and they definitely have dlc
planned for it see my previous video on
it what i don't think this means though
is that we have to necessarily be
worried about our own personal data on
our own machines the only thing affected
so far seems like bandai namco
themselves which would include their own
servers this means that the only thing
that black cat could have of yours is
stuff that you have related to bandai
namco games such as eldon ring that
would be stored on its service like your
specific character data or maybe your
elden ring login credentials but unless
you use the same password for everything
like between your bank account and your
video games you should be fine and if
you do use the same password for
everything maybe start changing it now
anyway consider yourself informed of the
current plight of bandai namco and
honestly sit back and enjoy the game
like usual while keeping an eye on
potential leaks unless you don't want
spoilers of course like this video if
you enjoyed being informed by yours
truly and hit that subscribe button if
you love elden ring and the world of the
lands between i happen to be a huge fan
as well and am planning on covering the
official eldon ring books which should
be arriving later this month either way
that's all for this one and i hope to
see you all next time this is bandit
signing out peace
[Music]
you